Hello Freak bitches.
There's not a lot of guys like you out there,
which is really interesting.
It's like you're a fast thinking,
fast talking,
very smart young guy who's also a conservative.
Like there's not a lot of those out there.
And this is one of the things that we're encountering today is there,
especially in college campuses,
there's this very strange separation between the left and the right to the point
where the right is like almost nonexistent or at least doesn't have any
representation.
And they're actively shunning that representation.
Like they're pushing people out.
I know what's going on with you in Berkeley?
Has that had been written seven resolved?
Yeah,
I think that,
uh,
so,
so Berkeley,
after the publicity they said they're going to explain to people if they don't
know the whole story.
Yes.
So UC Berkeley,
if you recall last year,
I actually spoke there before any of this happen and I spoke at UC Berkeley and
like April,
2016,
uh,
and then my low was supposed to speak there and he actually went there and there
was a riot,
were antifa infiltrated the,
the student community.
And there are all these pictures of them bombing things and you know,
blowing up cars and then understanding them in a fire at least and throwing
things at windows.
And so Berkeley shut down that event for safety reasons.
Then Ann Coulter wanting to speak there and they basically used what they called
time,
place and manner restrictions to stopper.
They kept sending,
well we have safety problems,
we can't figure out how to do the event.
And in the end they just canceled it because they didn't have security.
And then young Americans Foundation,
which sponsors me to go to a lot of these campuses,
they said,
we want Shapiro to come.
And again,
I spoke to like a year and a half ago and they give them two and a half months
advance.
And Berkeley said,
well,
we have no venues available.
And so this seemed to be another cover for,
we're not going to allow conservative on campus because are security problems.
So we made that public and then Berkeley said,
no,
no.
Well we'll make,
we'll make sure that you get in.
They give us an alternative venue and are they even said they'd covered the
security thinks they didn't like the bad publicity.
Oh,
well that's nice.
Yes.
That should be good.
Well,
you know what happened with Jordan Peterson yesterday?
Yes.
Yeah.
Just yesterday,
Jordan Peterson was banned from youtube and Youtube has a new policy that uh,
it's very,
it's very weirdly worded,
but apparently they're allowed to block and restrict any kind of videos that are
about religion or that could be deemed offensive,
which is almost everything.
Yeah,
that's right.
Anything that's remotely,
I mean,
anything that's interesting is,
is going to be offensive to somebody.
So won't be monetized.
It also won't be in the remote areas of interest or
I know they did this to a Prager university as well.
They'd blocked like 10 of their videos a couple of months ago.
So it's,
it's,
yeah,
I mean this is nasty stuff.
And listen,
Youtube as a private company,
they have the right to do what they want,
but don't proclaim that you're a free speech promoting institution if you're
going to block people like Jordan Peterson for God's sake.
Well,
the,
the problem is they're not blocking things that are offensive to other people
there.
They're not blocking certain things that are representing Islam in a positive
light.
That's right.
There's a,
there's a lot of weirdness with this left wing choice of what to sensor and what
not to censor and it's,
it's not just dangerous.
It's also bad for the whole idea of being progressive or being a liberal cause
it makes you look,
it makes them look really petty and really weird and really resistant and
hesitant to actually have real debate.
Yeah,
for sure.
And this is one of the reasons why I'm very meticulous in my terminology about
people who are on the other side of the aisle actually separate people who are
liberal from people who are left test.
So when there are people who try to ban speech,
I call them leftist and if they are not interested in banning speech,
then their liberal meaning they want bigger government.
They disagree with me on politics,
but they're still willing to have a conversation and they want an open forum.
People who are on the hard left think that it's actually an insult to their
identity to disagree with them.
And this is what I experienced sometimes on,
on campuses,
you know,
at cal state la where there's a near riot when I speak,
or University of Wisconsin where people stormed the stage and stand in front of
it and won't leave.
Or the state where we have,
again,
another near violence incident over at Penn state or DePaul where they actually
banned me outright.
So sometimes you get this routine,
uh,
from people who think that they conflate their viewpoint with their identity.
And then if you have a different viewpoint,
you're denying them their humanity.
And it's like,
no,
I'm not the nine year.
I just think what you're saying is dumb.
Good point.
That's a very good point is that they have their identity completely connected
with their ideology.
And when you oppose these people,
when you have these debates or these people,
what's really fascinating is the level of a stereo that gets reached while
you're staying calm.
Yeah.
That's what I've noticed is,
is that there's a ton of,
you know,
I,
I tend to keep relatively calm just as a human being.
And very often when I'm debating someone,
you see them getting more and more and more emotional and people on the right
love this because of course it's the triggering of the snowflakes,
right?
The easiest thing in the world to do is trigger some idiot college kid who
doesn't know his ass from a hole in the ground.
And it,
well,
what's,
what's hard to do is actually discuss issues with somebody who's intelligent
enough to make the,
to make the point.
But it's,
it,
the,
the level of hysteria on the campuses has really increased.
I mean,
I now have to travel with two members of security to every campus just cause you
don't know which campus is going to go off.
I never had to travel security before.
It's the weirdest thing in the world.